[Musique]
après la signature de la convention
cirest la ville de saint-andré le
département et cosmetic valley pour le
développement à grande échelle de
plantes à parfum et plantes médicinales
une journée agricole était organisée au
coeur de la nature de durée aujourd'hui
c'est une fête sur les papas main les
plantes médicinales et cosmétiques
puisque vous savez que le département
investit fortement dans ce domaine nous
avons d'ailleurs mené une étude pour
structurer la filière la renforcer faire
en sorte que et bien on crée
véritablement une filière économique sur
ces plantes médicinales en sachant que
la réunion est un point chaud de la
biodiversité
donc il ya un véritable potentiel
d'ailleurs l'étude s'est achevée pour
cette édition la manifestation est axé
sur le retour aux sources avec la
promotion de la filière plantes
médicinales des plantes à parfum sans
oublier des rencontres partage avec les
tisaneurs de la réunion
nos services en algérie que les gens
demandaient redemander au plan le
département soutient et développe
l'activité agricole c'est ce que nous
rappelle viviane ben hamida conseillère
départementale écouter aujourd'hui c'est
une belle manifestation qui met en
valeur nos plantes médicinales à nos
plantes à parfum et je dois dire que le
département est très heureux de s'y
associer
puisque nous sommes clairement chef de
file sur le développement de la filière
mais nous travaillons également sur le
volet commercialisation dont nous
travaillons surtout les toutes les
étapes de la filière le département et
ses partenaires se mobilisent à
promouvoir la filière des plantes
endémiques de la réunion
[Musique]